and i think the best thing for mike
fires kaif is you just said it's his
first start it's his first appearance
actually in 2021
he's a starting pitcher he's had 216
career appearances 197 starts
and
basically he knows how to pitch he knows
how to start this is a great great part
for him
[Applause]
strike three called on the inside corner
good start for fires
well the movement is a key only 88 miles
per hour so mike fires is not going to
blow you away with a fastball but that
kind of movement you take that any time
that's greg maddox type movement there
they're going to take their swings off
the left-hander there he is johnny means
making his sixth start 2-0 how about the
era folks
1.50 are you kidding me porn is hitting
170 one off of him has been better than
good
[Applause]
that's bounced to third ruiz up with it
and a quick efficient one two three
inning for john means
here's the one-two pitch by mike and dj
stewart takes on the inside corner
fastball bring him up second strikeout
for fires
and both looking here's murphy this is
the first at bat for this cleanup hitter
hit high and tonight right center field
mullins at the wall and
that baby's gone
sean murphy in his first major league
hit
was a home run exactly in the same spot
that he just hit this one
[Music]
pitch probably out of the strike zone
but he let it go got on top of a ball
tremendous power as we saw in saint pete
where he crushed the ball to the back
wall
454 feet estimated
so the a's get on the board first
tonight looks him over bends the back
knee and the 2-2 and a swing and a miss
strike three slider at 88
so some extra oomph there's means got
three strikes on sliders one two
strike three swinging another changeup
so means got three strikes on sliders
against moreland and he gets biscotti
here to swing through three changeups
back-to-back case you're in the second
1-2 pitch
swing and a miss good change-up and
cisco cut over it to the top of the
order let's see if the orioles can do
second time around because mike fires
has been on his game so far the 0-1 not
punting and this one's hitting the air
to right field down the line it's it's
deep it's in the corner it is gone
a home run for cedric mullins
that's why you don't bunt it for cedric
right now and this game is tied up at 1.
are you kidding me that pitch was way
inside mike fires tries to come back in
there again but not this time so two
solo homers in the game we're tied at
one
that's it well down the left field line
gone
back-to-back home runs from cedric
mullins and austin hayes and the orioles
have the lead
well how about you austin hayes huh two
home runs just a few games ago how about
this one off the bat 106 miles an hour
so cedric gets a fastball he turns it
around this is that change up for mike
fires left-handed battery against john
means the 1-2 pitch
and he looks at a call of strike three
right down the middle looks like he's
coming right back in again doubling up
hannah checked it no foul tip into the
glove
of chancisko so another strikeout
strikeout number four
[Applause]
wow what you see with the good ones and
he's a good one right now is
plenty of confidence from the pitcher
and not much from hitters right i mean
this is just pitching right
the 1-2 pitch
and that is a cold strike three
john means
is at it again cisco urias and mullins
8-9-1 for the orioles against mike fiers
right field and falls in for a base hit
so chance cisco
on board to lead off the oriole fifth oh
one
and a swing of the ground ball through
the left side past the dive of chapman
into left field cisco to third base he
will hold there ureas into second on an
absolutely scalded double
bounce to the right side that'll get a
run in
and it'll move the runner up as well so
good base running
cisco scores urrius gets over to third
and it's an rbi for cedric mullins his
second of the game
[Applause]
one two
and a wave and a miss a feeble cut by
biscotti he had no idea what was coming
and it was a change up down and away
seven strikeouts now for means who is
absolutely on cruise control he is
retired 11 in a row do i throw the pitch
that's working well or the pitch that's
working well or the pitch that's working
well or the pitch that's working really
well 2-2
and strike three called at the knees of
fastball 93 and andrews was frozen shut
eight strikeouts for means he struck out
two batters in each of the last four
innings and a new pitcher for the
athletics
buelos guerra
[Applause]
strike three called and
on the inside corner strike three caught
a little fist bump by garrett and he has
the three up through down inning we have
reached the seventh inning stretch
john means
doing his thing the 3-2 pitch swing and
a miss he pulled the string on the
changeup and down goes chapman
an amazing pitch by means
so mitch is over two
then he goes seven and get him out of
there
driven
right center
nobody's gonna get this one and that
baby is gone
so now it's a three to two game thanks
to the home run by
mitch morwin
well they needed to make some loud noise
mitch moreland all over a fastball at
the top of the zone
drives this thing out to right center
pack your bags folks
all aboard
next stop
on to the eighth inning sergio romo in
relief last night after the game that's
the swing rumble gets the strikeout
well i think romo should pitch in every
home game
and that is a strikeout so that's the
sergio romo we've seen for the last 13
years so here's paul fry pretty good
left-hander now he's a very good
left-hander but he's not cy young who
just left the game to go upstairs
and it's low tony kemp with a good
effect
ken brooks throw the second base is
not intact
he pitched to kenneth
not close
and the ball pops out of the glam of the
catcher and kemp's gonna get to third
oh wow
big time oh that's huge
big time down goes canna so two down
well paul frye is out and there's the
right-hander travis lakins senior
comes in with two out
breaking ball high fly ball should be
caught
mullins is there
and oakland is down in the eighth so the
tying run stays at third base
a's retired orioles still on top by a
run two on nobody down three balls one
strike to moreland
lined right to third they got him at
second double play
and bob melvin saying wait a second gee
whiz
thank you
thank you gibby so two outs now the a's
need to hit from elvis andrews 1-2 on
the way
should do it mullins waits
grabs it and the orioles win
wow that wasn't easy ben that wasn't
easy but that was an exciting game
another one valdez picks up his sixth
save of the year he is pumped up orioles
now have won
four of their last six ball games